[Music]
everything's bigger in texas
i should know i used to live here
but when big structures need to be
demolished
it requires skilled professionals who
can do it quickly
and safely and i want to know how it's
done that's why i'm going to learn from
one of the best
his name is dave burrows bobby hey
what's up man how you doing good to see
you yeah original name
yeah we're really good aiming things the
demo company
everyone thinks demo is just
sledgehammers
and having fun and just coming and
knocking down an entire building
we do that but really our bread and
butter is that selective demolition
instead of wrecking the entire building
a selective demolition is more dangerous
because
your people are in the building taken
apart part of the structure
but when things become unsafe a lot
could go wrong
someone can get hurt even worse someone
could get killed
so what's my actual job here your actual
job is you're gonna be the working
foreman
parker university is a local university
here in dallas they get destroyed by a
tornado about a year ago
we've been hired to go on the removed
portions of the building that are
structurally unsound
you plus three guys have a four hour
time period to remove 180 square foot of
concrete and steel
and i have four days to do it four hours
you're working for me
doesn't mean you sit back and point and
tell me what to do you have to show them
how to do the task and you're usually
the most skilled person on the crew
oh boy all right well the sooner we get
to work the sooner we get this done
right let's do it
so this is a small mock-up of the
structure you're going to demolish
tomorrow
the only difference is imagine when
you're standing on this you're on the
second floor of a building you're not on
the ground so you have
the steel joist which supports the
structure you have a metal decking on
top of steel joists that supports the
concrete and then you have a concrete
slab i think i need rosetta stone
because i don't know what language
you're speaking hey is all that
they're fancy words for you're gonna
remove the concrete and the steel that's
why i like that that's it
so first thing uh you need some
protective gear so there's some glasses
and gloves you're gonna need throughout
the day
and here is a pen and paper cause you
wanna take notes what's your call
notes or foreman take notes i didn't
come to do trigonometry
that's your call i came to break stuff
all right so now it's the fun part
you play with this and this big boy i
haven't known the guy for five minutes
and he's already handed me this big old
mean concrete song
i've done a little construction in my
life when i was younger but nothing like
this
just like an old weed eater it could
just easily pull just
i'd give it a good yank there you go
look at that man happening
to blow out my back step one we have to
make cuts in the concrete
to define the area that we'll remove
from the back is killing me
sawing in a straight line isn't easy but
more than that
here's what i learned about doing heavy
labor at my age
it hurts
i'm gonna be honest with you that's not
fun to do well the main reason your
back's killing you is because you're
trying to manhandle the tool look at
that line
yeah it's a little crooked yeah just a
little bit my first cut
not my best work but now that i've
learned how to cut the boundaries in the
concrete the second step is to remove it
time to show this slab what i'm made of
we'll start you with a sledgehammer
when doing this job we're chipping up
concrete you want to work your way out
of a corner
slide it up and all the all you got
all right bobby let me give it a shot
oh sledgehammering is no joke
oh it's a little heavier than i thought
swinging as hard as you can
man i bet when you break off a piece of
concrete it feels so good
is this trick concrete no it's just
concrete
all right and swing on all you got
there you go that was a great one yeah
get after it
there you go it's a little embarrassing
your weak friend here needs a little bit
of a break i got you oh
[Music]
you